excuse me have you subscribed yet it's
really good
hi guys welcome to Saturday a Saturday
is more often referred to as Friday
hurry but it's Saturday and I'm finally
editing it yay Saturday I look back at
my weekend vlog form so let's look back
on some of the stuff that's been going
on this week I'm free hi guys happy
Tuesday it is a pretty low-key day today
I just picked up a hobo on the way cuz
I'm boarding hey buddy
oh yeah lay on all the clothes that have
in the back of my car for months
goose is up boarding for a day and I'm
bringing her home and just kind of
getting done before heading back out on
the river for the nofilter show the day
after tomorrow
this one's worked up because oh no
biting I know you're so pumped because
we just did the yoga challenge and we
nailed it so she is so excited about it
you'll see that video soon this is our
Hans and Franz Halloween costumes as
well hmm
hello happy Wednesday everybody I just
washed my hair because wendy is coming
over to help me do my hair makeup even
though I have makeup from a meeting
earlier to get ready for a shoe box
event tonight shoe box is the company
branch off of hallmark that makes comedy
greeting cards and they're turning 29 so
they're throwing a birthday party at the
improv with a bunch of comedians and
there's gonna be like beer pong and all
kinds of stuff so Wendy's on her way
over but this is how casual this
Wednesday is going look at this little
thing oh hi are you having a casual
Wednesday - happy hump day goes
I'm not trying to grow hey hey how's it
good you know beer [ __ ]
yeah from the head Quinn windage ideas I
know from this angle you can't say that
you're getting your beard Shape I know
it looks like you're well it looks like
you can hear that and it looks like
you're just like cutting his face huh hi
guys happy Thursday we're getting ready
to go the airport and one of the tests
that we can do before we go to the
airport to go to the Seattle and simply
it's gonna fill the show space drop this
thing off it dog you take care to seal
your buddies you excited look straight
ahead if you're excited close enough
I made it with what time is it it's like
10:30 11 o'clock made it to my hotel in
Seattle yeah and all I gotta say is dams
yeah aka weird has happened in this room
yeah good morning and happy Friday
everybody drinking coffee wearing my
American flag shirt with the eagle on it
could I be more relatable to so many
different people right now it's Friday
and tonight we have our Seattle no
filter show being relatable sorry
Brandon I'm functioning correctly
too busy being relatable so relatable
goals app is told me I just shoot more
for friary right now this is what's
happening breathe no filter show while
the blood rushes to your brain and so
makes your hands more agile hey guys so
I am packing up to go to the venue right
now I'm gonna meet Hannah memory
downstairs and I want to take a quick
second to explain something I tweeted
out earlier today on Friday that the
release date of my book has been pushed
forward to February 2nd 2016 yeah yeah
and I celebrate because it's a really
good thing the thing that has happened
that I haven't been able to really talk
to you guys about too much is that I've
been writing I guess first and foremost
I write my book I wrote the last book
and I'm writing this book all of it
and so the stuff that I've been writing
for this book I don't I'm I'm I'm not I
just I'm like haha on it yeah feeling
you're like and so if I feel oh I don't
want to ask you to even like try and
like it so I am kind of refueling my
brain and giving myself some more time
to really make it the book that I want
to make it which is you know it has such
amazing potential and I've gotten rien
spired by some ideas for it and I think
it's gonna surprise a lot of you which
is great and that's the most fun right
so um so February 2nd it's still
available for presale I know it's weird
to say that when the books not
completely finished but I'm working my
brain off on it and I'm I'm so much more
excited and and way more relieved
knowing that there are it knowing that
there's now time to make it the thing
that I want to make it into the thing
that I'm proud of that
I feel great saying to you guys I'm so
proud of this please please make it part
of your life too kind of thing okay
enough of that now it's time to get to
the venue and dress up like I'm an idiot
and dance around
I guess that the girlie described yeah
we're sound checking and Hannah's on
sound checking because she can't get
down the stairs yay
because Jeffry and he is the most
amazing person look at the boys tonight
thanks krumitz yeah that's it we're done
our meet and greet for the Seattle no
filter show and look how empty it is
this is once so full of diarrhea jokes
and laughter
he's coming around
well there you go that's everything
that's been happening this week
currently I'm in San Francisco about to
go to our no filter show tonight which
will be the last show of this no filter
show tour excuse me I don't know